A controlled experience is kind of
the Holy Grail of scientific research.
In human subjects research, a controlled
experiment is where we get some
participants, randomly assign
them to certain conditions and
then treat each condition
in a different way.
What we do to each condition
is called a treatment and
then each group of participants
is called a condition.
Typically we have
a control condition and
an experimental condition where
the experimental condition
is where we're trying out something
that we're interested in.
Controlled experiments give really,
really nice generalizable and
clean results, but they're also
very difficult to do in education.
Usually in education,
we're working in real classrooms,
where we don't have the power
to randomly assign people.
And usually we'll want to do things that
last several weeks or several months.
And it's difficult to control for
everything when we're doing
controlled experiments.
But if you're interested in doing
a controlled experiment, in this lesson
we'll talk about the different
things that you need to be aware of,
different tools that
are available to you, and
different things you need to
make sure to control for.